Я практично навчився говорити українською.
Я бачу величезну кількість колег, друзів тут,
величезну кількість машин з білоруськими номерами.
і в цьому, звісно, велика перевага України над іншими країнами і сусідами.
Розробник платформи "Голос", на яку білоруси
завантажували свої бюлетені у день президентських виборів,
Павло Лібер вже два місяці живе в Україні і продовжує звідси працювати над проєктом.
Відомий в Білорусі ІТ-спеціаліст залишив Мінськ одразу після релізу платформи.
Завдяки "Голосу", над яким працювали 40 айтішників-волонтерів,
Білорусі провели паралельний підрахунок голосів
Білорусі провели паралельний підрахунок голосів.
Ми розуміли, щойно певний рівень інтересу дійде до нашого проєкту,
Звичайно, для своєї безпеки і безпеки проєкту нам було простіше виїхати,
щоб бути поза зоною досяжності білоруської влади.
Ті, хто не встиг виїхати, і мав хоч якесь відношення до цього проєкту, були затримані.
Нині, за оцінками Павла, до України переїхали
вже більше пів тисячі білоруських ІТ-спеціалістів.
Компанія, в якій він працює у Мінську, має офіс і в Києві.
Однак після двох місяців в Україні Павло Лібер
далекий від рішення залишитися жити і працювати тут постійно.
Сьогодні величезна кількість людей приїхали в Україну із Білорусі,
із ІТ-сфери, але поки вони приїхали, як і я, у так би мовити стані тимчасового очікування.
Сьогодні в Білорусі ІТ-сфера вмирає.
Ми розуміємо, що Україна може стати одним із гарних ринків для білоруського ІТ.
У більшості ІТ-компаній України співробітники платять близько 6% податків,
аналогічний айтішник з Білорусі, приїжджаючи сюди, платить понад 30%.
Я чую багато сумнівів від білоруських айтішників
саме через цю велику різницю в оподаткуванні.
У Мінцифри стверджують, Україна готова працевлаштовути та видати
десятирічні посвідки на проживання п’ятьом тисячам білоруських айтішників.
Для представників інших професій, які останнім часом переїхали в Україну з Білорусі,
знайти роботу і легалізувати своє перебування значно складніше.
Це на собі відчула білоруська активістка Божена Жолудь.
Вона збирала підписи на підтримку Світлани Тихановської та допомагала
з організацією мітингів у Гомельській області довіреним особам кадидатки в президенти.
Через постійні виклики до міліції і загрозу затримання
дівчина залишила своє містечко Речиця,
де працювала у державній дитячій лікарні, і переїхала до Києва.
Однак  влаштуватися в українській столиці виявилося непросто.
Ми пробували знайти роботу, але ми шукали офіційну
щоб була якась можливість зробити тут посвідку на проживання.
Маючи офіційну роботу, можна зробити вид на проживання тут,
але нам, по суті, і потрібна офіційна робота тільки для виду на проживання.
Тобто неофіційної роботи тут повно.
Про всі переваги і складнощі життя в Україні
добре знає білоруський журналіст Денис Лавнікевич
Він переїхав з родиною до Києва ще два роки тому.
Про життя білорусів в Україні розповідав у своєму телеграм-каналі.
Тепер по допомогу до нього звертаються ті, хто переїжджає нині.
Тут життя значно дешевше порівняно з Мінськом, значно дешевше,
дуже високий рівень і якість життя, можна легко влаштувати дитину до школи.
Приїхати - це одне, але, скажімо, отримати політичний притулок
досі було вкрай складно, не знаю, що зміниться зараз.
Складно легалізуватися через влаштування на роботу, бо багато має платити роботодавець
за такий дозвіл, тому люди починають шукати якесь українське коріння, предків,
але більшість на цьому етапі навіть не задумуються.
Переїхав, а вже тут починають розбиратися.
Саме так вчинила і білоруска Ульяна Тикун.
Дівчина працювала в команді Світлани Тихановської
протягом усієї президентської кампанії. У день виборів
вона поспіхом зібрала речі і поїхала до Києва.
Каже, залишатися в країні було вже вкрай небезпечно.
Здається, щонайменше семеро людей з цього знімку - за кордоном.
Двоє затримані, ще декількох вже випустили.
З кимось ми вже тут, у Києві, зустрічалися.
В Україні Ульяна присвятила себе роботі з діаспорою.
Вона консультує співвітчизників щодо легалізації,
допомагає влаштувати побут і знайти нових знайомих.
Однак сама не приховує: Київ - лише транзитна точка у її маршруті.
Дівчина хоче переїхати до Польщі чи іншої європейської країни.
Узагалі мій план такий, щоб у найближчі декілька років
набратися максимально знань та досвіду тут,
увібрати в себе усе найкраще, що є в Європі, в Україні і вже їхати у Білорусь,
де, на жаль, буде випалене поле, коли зміниться влада.
Зараз там усе знищується. І ось там,
на тому випаленому полі, робити якісь проєкти з відновлення білоруської культури.
А от художник Олексій Кузьмич переконаний: найкращий час творити у Білорусі - саме зараз.
У день виборів президента 9 серпня Олексій роздягнувся,
прикріпив на груди бюлетень із зображеним фалічним символом
та став у позу розп’яття спочатку на виборчій дільниці,
а потім - між шеренгою ОМОНу і протестувальниками.
Таким чином він хотів показати абсурдність владних амбіцій Лукашенка і його команди.
Вже за декілька тижнів після акції Олексій дізнався від знайомих,
що йому хочуть інкримінувати статтю, пов’язану з порнографією.
Аби уникнути цього, митець переїхав до Києва.
Каже, що почувається тут як вдома, бо має українську кров і багато друзів.
Однак хоче повернутися на Батьківщину за першої ж нагоди.
Тут є невеликий парадокс, бо, з одного боку, я всіма силами
борюся проти цього режиму, а з іншого боку - цей режим і процеси, що відбуваються,
я використовую як матеріал для свого мистецтва, тому, коли влада зміниться,
то сенсу мені працювати в Білорусі, якщо там почнеться такий цукерково-букетний період,
сенсу бути не може. Я поїду в Росію чи якусь іншу країну
і продовжуватиму свою діяльність там.
У те, що спротив білорусів у нинішньому його вигляді досягне результатів,
Олексій Кузьмич не вірить.
За свободу треба платити і часто це плата кров’ю.
Я дуже сподіваюся, що наша країна цього уникне, але водночас
без наполегливості і прояву волі ніякої свободи ти не отримаєш. Це 100%.
Віра в те, що політична епоха Олександра Лукашенка в Білорусі таки добігає кінця -
основна причина, чому білоруси сприймають Україну лише як тимчасовий прихисток.
Я думаю, що все-таки наша візьме, і він відпустить людей,
яких затримав, і піде. Гадаю, що це недаремно. Все-таки це вже
внесло зміни в обстановку в Білорусі, люди якось почали бачити, перестали боятися.
Навіть у моєму місті люди почали виходити без страху, особливо на жіночі акції.
У білорусів, які переїхали в Україну незадовго до виборів чи вже під час протестів,
є законні 90 днів для перебування у країні.
Цей час для багатьох спливе в жовтні-листопаді.
Після цього легально залишитися в країні зможуть лише ті, хто отримають
посвідку на тимчасове чи постійне проживання або попросять про статус біженця.
Однак, за даними Міграційної служби України, за понад місяць
антилукашенківських протестів такий запит на визнання біженцем
чи прохання про додатковий захист
наразі оформили лише двоє громадян Білорусі.